and the pandemic is adding another layer
of difficulty to life in gaza
vaccination uptake there remains low
among the territory's 2 million
inhabitants and as dw middle east
correspondent tania kremer reports from
gaza city covet 19 is further straining
an already weak health system at a time
when the economy is struggling and
people are trying to rebuild
here in the center of gaza city and
already street workers are still
clearing the rubble of a building
destroyed in the conflict between israel
and hamas in may one of the several
continuing crises
a few blocks away dr shady award and his
team have been fighting the coronavirus
pandemic at gaza's largest hospital
alcifa hospital
this award is dedicated to testing and
treating patients suspected of having a
covet 19 infection
while the number of seriously ill
patients has slightly decreased in
recent days infection rates remain high
we used to categorize these cases some
cases went back home and were treated at
home there are cases that are admitted
and treated in the hospital and there
were cases sent to intensive care
it will be approximately now a month for
us in this wave this has been the
largest and most intense wave since the
beginning of the coronavirus pandemic
inside the gaza
the staff are exhausted the doctor says
over 1 500 people have died of covet 19
in gaza the pandemic has further
strained an already weak health system
and dire economy the small territory
ruled by the militant group hamas has
been effectively cut off by israel and
egypt for the past decade
although scarce in the beginning
vaccines have become increasingly
available but more people need to take
them still we will work with the
community in engagement with the
community and help the authorities here
to spread the facts and the safety of
the vaccine and to encourage people to
get the vaccine at the moment gaza
has reached 40 percent of vaccination
among the targeted population
roughly 1.2 million out of gaza's 2
million inhabitants are eligible to get
a job at a vaccination center like this
one
authorities have made vaccinations
mandatory for certain categories of
people
such as those working with the public
however reactions are mixed
in gaza there are a lot of problems
crowdedness a lot of mixing when dealing
with each other in the workplace schools
among students even with the elderly our
society is very intertwined so
vaccination is very important i took the
first and second doses of the sputnik
vaccine and now they send us
here people are generally not so
concerned about taking precautionary
measures they don't care about corona as
before i feel that people are going
along with this circumstance maybe the
thing that matters is the economic
situation here
[Music]
while the pandemic continues to weigh on
daily life it is just one of the several
ongoing crises people have to deal with
in gaza